I have Russ do you come here often
yeah oh whoa whoa whoa gosh
oh [ __ ] I'm a bit I gotta pay on him
I shan't I got throw-up [ __ ] this place
is a [ __ ] dump look at that [ __ ] ass
look at that good whoa whoa whoa what
what is that a [ __ ] Star Wars
reference with the table it looked like
Han Solo oh it's just a [ __ ] out of
that I don't really get what I'm doing
here this is the best [ __ ] game ever
[ __ ] made look at those bitter
[ __ ] rock-solid if I ever create
another nightclub I know what am I gonna
name it at least I'm pretty sure this is
the Star Wars reference with a carpet or
whatever the [ __ ] that is all right that
plus sign is apparently a health station
I didn't realize that because I'm a JD
yes okay I'm an idiot
yes all right finally we can get rid of
this [ __ ] drug test
it really gets [ __ ] out ahead quick
with this alcohol
I always eyes I'll better write a
healthy that Glasgow [ __ ] love is
music it's so awesome alright we're
gonna push this now the doctor is going
on huh huh dropping the bass girl
tonight cut this glove winner go no no
no no don't you dare fall down ah why
don't you tell Wingo I just dig it music
there we go there we go NABBA go go go
how this [ __ ] are bad I didn't see
that [ __ ] what did i do a tank then I
open this hole I need to be drunk to be
down here I want to get drunk again
[ __ ]
what what am i what what what in heaven
Oh big booty [ __ ] I love big booty
[ __ ] [ __ ] a sub I am this is so
[ __ ] dumb this is like Dumbo on a new
level it's that's how [ __ ] dumb it is
uh can you guess what I'm supposed to do
because I don't think we can guess this
you see that fat guy in the metal dance
egg with no [ __ ] well we got a [ __ ]
pee on him
the game that makes you pee on people
that's a good game in my bag and your
game that okay I need to humans to be in
the right spot done oh no I know how to
do it now I doubted that yeah [ __ ] yeah
I'm big on people
oh you like that oh you like that don't
you a little bit on best game ever 10
out of 10 10 out of 10
wonderful stop you can stop hitting now
conquered geez
right father we need an aspirin I would
really
I think that's what they do in the club
I wouldn't know about it okay well let's
see on this I mean let's take an aspirin
I need an aspirin
oh wait I need to empty my peepers well
I guess I can see around i watch i watch
you're not dad yeah I got you daddy
[ __ ] a little bit oh yeah all right
time to drink there's my way of Mass
Effect 3 or 2 sorry
oh well [ __ ] please play my super-good
yeah all right well we have a rock here
we can push no not that way
do not draw that way I'm a pay young man
but I am not too gay okay let's push
thing don't you dare [ __ ] my rock [ __ ]
I said Rock that [ __ ] Jesus okay okay
don't you dad don't you dad
they had an odd [ __ ] man she [ __ ] me
No oh she's stuck now aren't you no what
are you not a [ __ ] all OH
faster-faster-faster just just heavy yes
but no [ __ ] out I love this song is
actually I chat again you better let me
pee on you oh [ __ ]
Plan B flambe hi miss me oh [ __ ] what am
i doing
pay on him already there we go down yeah
yes
yeah don't know that that's aa blah da
da na na na oh it missed me thank you
Jesus I will try to be better from now
on
hold up no he's gonna start throwing up
again [ __ ] it means your cow shed don't
you gamble while I pay yet
Oh down you go boy
yes yes I never been so well in my life
they're all dead
[ __ ] yeah my betcha spray and my monitor
and a [ __ ] [ __ ] where you got Mary
just she just strength of another day
reckon I do with my head
Oh what what take its time delete it
right I think so joke okay as it as I
[ __ ] hate clubs like this alright oh
there that's alright excellent
hey I'm here hurry up hey you want your
[ __ ] in I know she ate it
you're kidding can't wait to get jet
packs and banners and the [ __ ] best
[ __ ]
I'm leaking money that's how [ __ ]
rich I am can I go now thank you
waitwhat me that's my mother
I don't want to see the boss out there
yeah
what the hell are you doing with my girl
firstly either taste well now she just
watches sister fell me sure this is the
gun I tried to steal my job that's mine
got to say for yourself ain't got to say
[ __ ] for you um what oh hey hey Barry
how you doing hey do you know this Terry
yeah like I'd associate with a caveman
what does not seem to know you
what last Margo you can't forget it I
gotta go powder my nose
daddy yeah wait let's get back to
business
what I just got one thing to do what
I'll be with you in a minute
people I gotta show the appropriate
levels of respect miss step out of line
you can expect to be respected back
what's one of you guys show no respect
what is I don't know what could have
been Frankie
oh [ __ ] uh Brenda what is it oh [ __ ] oh
[ __ ] you're not even calling
dieter - - - Debra - ha ha ha
parlez uh nah uh look you know you can
have the money I bet I've got more money
you can have that too if he was oh no
out of my belly come on can you get me
the money but you gotta do me a little
job first oh [ __ ]
a job oh yeah but I mean you know I'm
gonna have to I'll have to consider it
first I mean what is it what but I have
to do good good
so dad you're accepted oh shut up this
way okay here's the plan
we got ourselves a little problem fact
several no problems like I've already
got the disguise so that's that won't
cover huh what else she is one of these
it's called
a bomb these are the prop nah my brother
who they came from I don't know they
seem totally out of place in this
ecosystem they're here and there are my
match so what I propose that you do is
use your disguise
Edgar one take the bomb through here
down here
out of here what Oh drop it
yeah I know I know by the way when that
bomb goes off s additionally ship tail
and if you don't pull it off let's just
leave town oh [ __ ] it's burning
ah I got it I got it I got a bomb I
don't want anybody what do I do video Oh
Joe Joe Joe w a definite no no no no I
everyone to tell everybody tell him to
have it over the evidence
oh [ __ ] if I get hit once I die
really oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
well if only I could see with his
[ __ ] camera angle I'm not gonna kill
your family or anything like that just
get a [ __ ] murder you all go cogito
oh [ __ ] yeah I don't wait oh no buddy no
no I don't want a game like that I'm so
dumb oh [ __ ]
oh that guy was ok with that [ __ ] not
that
yeah yes yes yes no puedo
yes there we go well that's their shed I
got a Jota it's going out come on let's
go
there we go what the [ __ ] am i doing
whoa that was [ __ ] luck I think it's
over here
where the hell am I going
I feel like I just went in circles
uh every our
hariya Michael the next no way no way no
[ __ ] way it exploded that are you
[ __ ] serious
no no no no way
No
hi
[ __ ] please hi
right